Now before we dive deeper into the algorithms, I want to make one important point.
When you use randomness in computation, there is sometimes a danger of taking the poking around
that I mentioned in my topic before this unit a bit too literally.
So some people when they see an NP complete problem or an NP hard problem
and NP complete of course being for the decision problem and NP hard for the optimization problem,
just terminology means both problems are hard.
And then some people would just say--oh this is NP complete and this is NP hard,
well let's just try very, very many random solutions and pick the best one,
which of course works better if you have an optimization problem than a decision problem,
trying many random solutions sounds easy, actually it is easy,
and you trust that the solution that it produces will be good enough.
Well, sometimes you have no better choice than that,
but in my mind I think you're playing a dangerous game and I want to illustrate this for you.
So let's say that we play a game and the rules of the game are as follows--
you bet an amount x whatever you want and then you throw a die and of course, the value
can be 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, or 6, and if you throw a number between 1 and 5, I will give you back
x+30% of x, and if you throw a 6, I'll give you back 0.
Now my first quiz for you and again this involves a bit probabilities should you play this game,
and let's say you can play as often as you want--